part 2b
region s is the base of a solid whose
cross sections perpendicular to the
x-axis are squares
find the volume of the solid
all right so region s we see it right
over here in the last part we already
said that this function is f and this
function is g
you could try out some values and think
about how they behave or you could uh
get a sense that hey look a fourth
degree quadratic is going to have these
ups and downs like that while the
something well this is it has an x term
but then it has an exponential term
right here that might have more of a
kind of an upward trend especially as x
increases and then an upper trend also
as x becomes more and more negative
because this exponent is going to become
positive so you can think about them in
different ways like that but what's
important is region s and there's a
couple of things we have to think about
we have to think about the bounds of
region s we know that the upper bound of
region s x is equal to we know x is
equal to 2 here but we don't know this
value
right over here we don't know let's just
call that a i'll put a question mark
over there we don't know what this x
value is but we do know that at that x
value the functions are going to be
equal to each other so we know that it
that f of a is going to be equal to g of
a or another way in the last section we
talked about the absolute value of f of
x minus g of x which we've already
inputted into our calculator and saved
it
we could also say that the absolute
value of f of a minus g of a
is equal to zero and you don't need the
absolute value there because obviously
the absolute value of zero is going to
be zero but we've already inputted this
into our calculator so it's going to be
useful so we can solve that thing we
inputted into our calculator how does
when does that equal zero and actually
let's let's just do that right from the
get-go
so in our calculator we already input it
right over let's make sure it's on
in our calculator we already input
inputted the absolute value of f of f of
x minus g of x and so we can use our
solver now to figure out when does that
equal zero it actually equals zero just
in the where we see it it equals it one
time two times and three times so we
want to find this place right over here
we want to figure out what x is or what
a is so let's
look at the math functions actually
let's clear this and actually let me
quit that mode and so let's go to math
and scroll down to the solver
the solver
and let's see we want to redefine okay
so we want to see so we can go to the
original screen of the solver and
actually i did this in the previous
problem although we redefined y sub 1
but you say okay when does 0 equal y sub
1 or when does y sub 1 that's this year
equal 0
and so you press
enter and then we could put an initial
guess this looks someplace in between
zero and two so i'll put an initial
guess of one and let's see what it
gravitates to oh whoops and then i could
do
alpha
solve
alpha solve let's let it munch on it a
little bit
let's let it
munch
it's going and there you go it got to
1.03 which is the one we want it didn't
go to
x equals zero or x equals two it got
went to 1.03
so a is approximately equal to 1.03 so a
is approximately equal to 1.03
and so what integral do we take we don't
want just the area of s we're saying
that s is the base and we of and if we
take a cross section we're going to have
squares so this is going to be a base of
a square so this length right over here
is going to be the absolute value of f
of
of f of x
minus g of x
that's the length of the base but if we
want the area of that cross section you
can imagine let me draw it at a little
bit of an angle here so you have a cross
section of a square there you have a
cross section of a square here
and so the the area of each of those
cross sections is going to be the length
of the base squared and then you
multiply that times the little dx's you
get that volume of the craw of each of
those little sections and you sum them
all up and then you are going to get you
already get the volume of that figure
so the volume of that figure
is going to be equal to so the volume
is going to be equal to
the integral from
x equals a
all the way so that's approximately you
know approximate well i'll just write a
over here to x equals 2
of
this business this is the length of one
side of the square but we want to square
it because that's going to give us the
area of that cross section and then
let's do that
so times i could say the absolute value
of f of x minus g of x
i could just square that or if i want i
could just put parentheses there i'll
actually leave it as absolute value
since that's what i've already inputted
into my into my calculator
and so that's going to give the area of
each of those cross sections
perpendicular to the x-axis and you
multiply it times dx you get the volume
of that little section and then you add
them all up from a equal from x equals a
to x equals two and luckily we've
already done a lot of the work here on
our calculator
our value of a is stored in the variable
x already so let me quit this and then
so let me go back to my math functions
let me go to
definite integral or function integral
select
select that
and now i'm not going to do y sub 1 i'm
going to do y sub 1 squared so
let me do variables
y variables it's a function y sub 1
and i'm going to
make sure i'm going to square it
that's what i do right over here my
variable of integration is x i'm going
to do it from
x
the value of a is stored in the variable
x in my calculator right now it's a
little confusing this first x is a
variable of integration the next x is my
lower bound of integration and then my
upper bound is two
and so the most complex part here is
some of the shortcuts i'm doing with the
calculator
and we let the calculator munch on it
and it's approximately 1.283
so
it's approximately 1.283
cubic units and we are done